his Parliament searches for insight on
the car emissions scandal MEP s on the
emissions committee turned the heat on
more former European commissioners
responsible for industry and the
environment between 2010 and 2014 nem
eps suspecting favoritism to the auto
industry demanded to know why so little
legal action was taken against them in
view of the evidence I do is do see a
huge difference between for instance the
way that the Commission dealt with air
quality legislation starting with 22
infringement procedures and with your
responsibility in this field without any
action towards member states
non-traditional sleep on cydia Theo
nailed a procedure inflection equal
Everett elementary guardo no a directive
a solo valid a dalarian on Ella dear
ativa quadro non Sharon a tsunami
portato provo indeed see catchy fossils
that defeat devices an inquiry committee
was set up to probe the often gigantic
difference between laboratory and
real-world tests and to recommend ways
of legislating for more accurate
emissions measuring as you were member
of the College of Commissioners do you
think you did enough to tackle emissions
thank you to be frank with you it's
wrong thing to ask only if the
Commission was right or wrong I I have
already answered I think we could do
more it's really important that we all
understand that each of us was not doing
its part of the job properly